gosh darn it the rune in my childhood
no wait that was the that was the one
from a few years ago this one
is gonna be the sequel we deserve
ghostbusters afterlife trailer
number two now we got a bunch of
notifications that this trailer was out
from all these trailer sites they were
all removed which usually means
they got a bunch of blocks so i don't
know i'm hoping this can get up on
youtube if this
is blocked by sony we'll see what we can
do to work around
getting our reaction delivered to you
guys as we met up at 7 30 to do this so
yeah i'm determined to get this
up now just due to the time of the day
and plus i'm really looking forward to
this movie man ivan wrightman's
twit twits tweeter twitter i can't speak
everyone's yesterday are just getting me
that much more excited for this film
let's see what's in store and hopefully
you guys can see it with us
a great mom i don't know i'm fine
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
[Music]
here we go there's some trouble for you
[Music]
her first yeah
the sun have i been written in here
somehow
maybe it's the apocalypse
the commercial
wow full-on apocalypse
oh my whoa
slimer
[Music]
oh wow it looks like this stuff from was
it 84
when that all that stuff was going down
in the first goes festival i think so it
looks like whatever's awakening is all
linked to the events from that like
everything that the ghostbusters had
preserved you know i have the finale of
ghostbusters when the
with [ __ ] whatever that's what that
service character name
just because bill murray calls him that
unleashes a havoc upon new york city it
kind of looks like that's what's going
on in this
mining field this oil yeah yeah yeah
there's something awakening under from
underneath the earth
spreading here and the reason i was
saying that was because you have the
the looks like the terror dog from the
first ghostbusters movie
zulu and gatekeeper and then of course
you have slime right here
can't do a ghostbusters movie without
your slime involved but then it looks
like there's a bunch of other
things going on that maybe they're from
the adventures
of the original ghostbusters that are
being kind of contained here or they've
awakened something else entirely
different like you do see this egyptian
statue
i think this was kind of cool about this
is that the first teaser trailer had
more of just the small town
home vibe as a family it felt like that
family drama
sort of toned away something that jason
reitman excels at this one
capitalized like still had that flair
where it's character driven where it's
about the small town family it looks
like the main characters and not beyond
finn wolfe are actually the paul rudd
character and this
phoebe mckenna grace yeah yeah the
female finn wolfhard who is also in
everything now
yeah yeah she's great it's also about
legacy because they're the grand
children of uh harold raimi's character
so it was nice getting
the janine character back i didn't know
she was actually gonna be in this i'm
assuming that's where janine and egon
lived this home because they must have
settled down and
had a great life together for some
reason my mind never even went there
with spangler
yeah that's right he would have had to
have had a wife in order to have had
grandchildren yeah so i mean janine had
kids
no he just he just adopted he was just a
foster home
that's how he spread his love around
never factored in that she would most
likely be in this movie so yeah it's
about honoring the legacy of all that
too
that's the second time i've said legacy
and it's the second time you've left why
is that making you laugh so much
well because because the position this
movie is in is is
it has to be absolutely reverent to the
legacy and it has to
nod to the legacy in ways that the
previous film in most people's eyes
failed to do
so you know it feels very requisite very
laugh-worthy
i find it amusing because of course
because you have to but
but despite my cynicism yes
hahaha despite my cynicism
realized there was going to be citizen
involved with this well
i you know ghostbusters has gotten
contentious in the past
several years and this movie does have
an onus placed upon it to satisfy where
the previous film
upset everybody i mean it plays in
earnest and yeah i like
the contrast of having this small town
vibe with yeah what are these
earthquakes about what's going on here
and you know changing it up drastically
from being in new york city and having
you know it's just a different
world and so i liked the kind of quieter
pace that
will probably ramp up into a whole lot
of crazy chaos because you know
ghostbusters movies do get pretty huge
and i also love the
array of effects here like it looked
like there was one practical looking
ghost in the diner the civil war hat on
and then you've also got the more sort
of fantastical beast-like ghosts and
whatnot and then yeah you have your
nods to the original cast but in fun
sort of cheeky ways like yeah janine
showing up kind of giving them the brief
you get the teas
of dan aykroyd i'm sure bill murray is
going to show up at some point but
you know boomers confirmed the return
for this yeah everybody is
except for obviously harold ramis it
looked like the
nicest most natural way you could
incorporate those things i mean i don't
know exactly why they're calling dan
aykroyd i'm sure he'll get involved in
some way shape or form but yeah well it
seems like they rely mainly on using
ghostbusters tech
in order to save the idea but i'm saying
are they gonna call him up for like four
minutes worth of advice or is he
actually gonna join the plot in some way
or is it just gonna be like fact-finding
like hey how does your ghostbusters
machine work such a cynic
attitude in this one you seem so upset
well because it's damn right i didn't
realize ghostbusters could have
triggered such a big party you know you
have to include them to a degree
and sometimes that feels perfunctory and
sometimes it feels very natural
to do that because of the fact that they
are linked to the family here this isn't
like the ghostbusters reboot that
happened because this one
is the link to the family the only way
to save the day is because with using
the actual
tech design by the original ghostbusters
team i don't think it would be a
perfunctory situation it would have to
be something where
they really need to know what it is
they're dealing with they would need
people who are actual
experts the ghostbusters seem to have
been completely forgotten
you see dan aykroyd like a little tease
of him here he looks like he's got his
own little shop he's all tatted up looks
like he's totally left the ghost busting
life behind
so this could also be the kind of call
where it's like
people have forgotten about them these
things don't really happen anymore but
now we need them
in order to help understand what it is
that we're dealing with so to me
like everything's kind of just lining up
seamlessly here
something that the ghostbusters reboot
whatever
opinion you had of it or not it really
feels like that movie was mainly just
caring more about comedy more than
anything else
and then here this is bringing you back
towards
uh the sense of wonder that the first
ghostbusters actually
provided it's not the kind of wonder
that i necessarily associated with the
first
ghostbusters but you know putting this
with the main characters being children
you do get that childlike almost amblin
entertainment
aesthetic to it all with uh paul rudd
looking like he's giving a really
sincere performance you know
yeah like i don't get sarcastic paul
running here i'm sure he'll have some
funny moments i actually
buy him a lot in the role of this like
professor
character every man science teacher yeah
absolutely and i like the detail to
sound all good about this now
and i like the details of them watching
the ghostbusters
throughout their impressions because the
guys will get uploaded onto youtube
everyone associates
no one's ever accused you of liking
everything
nope never not once not once again i
don't think
critically i never think critic yeah
you're not known to obviously
see what's in front of me i say yes give
me more
bigger is always better quantity over
quality
guys what do you think about this
ghostbusters app don't ask him but what
did you guys think about it are you
excited that we're getting an
actual sequel versus a reboot leave your
thoughts down below
what did you think about the
ghostbusters 2016 film i'm sure that's
gonna lead to a very positive
conversation i hope you read all the
comments on that one
subscribe hit that like button and hey
let's shout out some patrons ryan
rosenthal
kevin gail ferguson that's caleb
sharon winner stackster crook
cliff rodriguez chris
bustin mr crispy
aaron myers danny pancake
alex beaver kathleen mayer
pseudonymous entity love the adult guy
now santa dicky kelly hails
levi o'dell josh barnes sean dawn
oscar warren american
pater pacheco thank you all for joining
our patreon page of supporting us at
this tier
your support means more to me than it
does to john
screw you buddy burn in hell you guys
ascend with me
to our lord and savior thank you so much
man
[Music]
you